all right norman yes sir welcome back
glad to be back so what's the latest
with you well the latest is uh for those
who wanted to know
uh did i nail the interview that monday
yeah i kicked his ass
i'm currently working for the this
company um
we're not getting paid yet i'm in the
training process because after after i
finish the training process we'll be
testing
and i'll be getting what you call a cpm
which is a certified property management
uh certificate and um that's pretty good
you know i'm working um it's a 35 unit
uh building
they house veterans with uh severe ptsd
uh 85 of them are ex-addicts or
using addicts now because they have harm
reduction that's that's put in place so
that within itself is a blessing you
know how do i get to a point to where
god blesses me to move away from that
in order to move me into a position in a
situation
where people are just like me
and may need a helping hand yeah who
better than you you know
i mean you talk am i grateful when you
do
i'm grateful that god has bestowed upon
me to even
have a job this this this place gave me
a brand new laptop that i work on
i haven't sold it they trusted me
they're entrusting me and the blessing
about that is
did nobody trust me
i didn't even trust myself and there are
some times
where i don't trust myself
but god is there situation being the
other day i was coming home
and the police were chasing the guy and
he dropped his dope sack
and i seen it now immediately the attic
mine kicked in
norman look you got no money times are
tough
you're sober you can take this you can
sell this
and it just went on and on for a minute
all i said was god be with me
i walked past it and when i turned
around
another car was coming around the corner
they opened the door and they went right
straight to that sack
see it doesn't just because i'm sober
and i'm not using doesn't mean that the
attic mind doesn't kick in
it kicked in but most importantly i did
something about it
the best thing i could do about it pray
because usually i wouldn't believe in
prayer remember god and i had a problem
now we don't i called on him he helped
me
and walked me through it that was very
important for me
because if i would have took that
and those police came around that corner
i'm gone i wouldn't be talking to you
right now so thank god for that
um the job is is
how would i put this it's nourishing for
me
you know because it's uh it's it's an
older building that was restored
and it's 35 units it's pretty small but
it's really nice
but i'm able to help some people i'm
able to be of service
you know um if you don't know
no low income tax credits uh hud housing
and things like that
it'll be a very difficult job luckily
god has blessed me to work for companies
in the past
doing this stuff which led me to
position where i know exactly what i'm
doing they've given me five tests
already
i scored a hundred percent on all five
it's not bragging
it's not trying to toot my own horn but
thank god i got the ability to even
go through a test because i know that i
have the aptitude and
the ability to do it
but what about those times when i just
said no
sometimes i think about those times um
it's christmas time i know of course i
miss my mom i miss my grandmother
i miss my family in general but it's
okay
it's a little hard right now because
they cut the food stamp thing off i'm
not getting paid from the job but i'm
still work but it's okay
you know why it's okay because goddammit
that's exactly what it's supposed to be
see and i respect it more because i
remember those times where i
disrespected it
and didn't care see usually i'd be
running around acting a [ __ ] fool
but i'm not it's not that i'm
self-centered or self-seeking i'm just
i'm just into doing the best that i can
right now one day at a time because
futuristically when i look further than
i'm supposed
to i [ __ ] up so god is allowing me to
learn from my past i don't have to
hold on to it like i have i don't have
to
use it as an excuse as i have but i can
learn from it
because i remember those times when i is
a i still have a place to stay with my
buddy
we have we have a little food we're
going to get we're going to get some
more
somehow someway you're in a tent still
you're in a tent no i mean donald's i'm
gonna stay at donald's
oh wait so yeah yeah we got the
refrigerator we got
yeah we got it it's we don't have
a lot but i thank god for the minimum
and the other day i was thinking because
for two days i was thinking about thank
god for the minimum
thank god for the minimum thank god for
the minimum and so when i went on my
meditation the other morning i sat
because i go into little tokyo in los
angeles and i sit by this pond that has
these goldfish
you know and they're very therapeutic
for me
and i kept thinking i was like why do
you want me
to appreciate to to to be grateful for
the minimum
and what came to me was so you'll
appreciate the maximum
so if i'm grateful for the minimum i'll
more so appreciate the maximum when it
comes
i won't be selfish and self-centered i
will i'll be conscious enough to know
that guess what i moved from here to
here
and i did it with god's help not about
me it's not all about me
you know my friend is struggling and uh
he's he's really struggling man
and it hurts because i i i have to i
live with him
and watch somebody just
just just man just just tear themselves
down i try
i try my best but as god is instituted
in me to do one thing and one thing only
be my shining light you know i mean he
is it'll happen when it happens of
course it hurts me
because that's my friend you know out of
everybody
even when i was down and out he let me
in his house
i didn't have any [ __ ] food he had a
minimal very minimal amount of food
he gave me something to eat he allowed
me to wash my ass
he let me sleep on his floor
still he's doing this so
i'm going to pray for him i'm not going
to excuse myself for crying because
sometimes some people say
well man it's not so supposed to cry
what the [ __ ] do i have tear ducts for
why do i have emotions you know i love
that brother because he's a good brother
and all i want you know is the best for
him so it'll happen when it happens
yeah just if you want it doesn't mean
yeah he's ready yeah it has to come in
his time yeah
so the other day i ran into a good
friend of mine who went through
elementary school with me from
kindergarten to the sixth grade
and he was really struggling but he knew
he knew who i was
now you're talking 40 plus years ago
and i asked him i said hey man how you
doing he says man
this crystal meth in this crack it's
tearing me apart
you said my marriage is gone and
everybody just
doesn't want to be bothered with me
and i asked him i said why do you do it
he said because i really just don't want
to deal with anything
i said well just do me a favor i said
take my number down
and call me anytime i said i want you to
know this i said i don't know
know how long i have i said but i've
been clean for a little minute just a
little minute i don't know how long
because i don't count two days
i said just believe in god and ask him
to take it away from you
and he said okay his mom called me
this morning and that woman said you
know i just want to thank you
she said i don't i don't remember you
his mother is 90 plus years old
she said i don't remember you but he
told me you guys went to school together
she said whatever you said to my son
thank you
and i said well you know she says no
honey
whatever you said to that boy it touched
him
she said a man has not touched anything
in four days
and you know i'm a very emotional guy
man you know i cry like a baby like i
got tears in my eyes now
because you know come here from me come
on you know the crackhead norman
one check norman smoke up everything
norman
how the [ __ ] do you put me in a position
to where i wasn't looking at doing
anything
but just saying a kind word and his mom
called me and she said a prayer for me
on that phone
my buddy wasn't there i cried like a
baby
and i just thank god for putting me in a
position like this
to to be his shining light and to do his
bidding and not my own
just i just want to help people which in
turn helps me
you know even the negative comments
some people say well you haven't done
anything well guess what that's your
opinion
as long as i feel within myself that
i've done something
and i have all these positive comments
the positive always outweighs the
negative
you know so i'm gonna keep on keeping on
i'm gonna keep on doing exactly what i'm
doing in order to get where i need to go
i don't know where i need to go i know
where i would want to go
but god knows exactly where i'm going
so i'll just ride that train and with
that everybody have a good holiday
you know eat enough don't get sick thank
you very much
for your prayers and your just being you
thank you so very much thank you very
much all right
you look great thank you that [ __ ] broke
my [ __ ] heart man that lady
she was crying i'm like oh my god she
said whatever you said to him
yeah he's been he's been clean for four
days
from kindergarten to the sixth grade but
isn't it great to be able to help
somebody
like that yeah